[Müzik]
Okul eşyaları. Okul eşyalarını
artikeline göre de, dust yani ayrı ayrı
sınıf sınıf anlatacağız. Çünkü gramer
kuralları Almancada artikele bağlıdır. O
yüzden kelimeleri ezberlerken artikel
ile birlikte ezberlemek en güzeli. Hemen
D artikeli olan kelimelerle başlayalım.
diştiftı tekil derstift çoğulu dişiftı
bir kelimenin sonunda stift kelimesi
varsa demek bu bir tür kalemdir ve
artikele de her zaman için sona baktığı
için de olur.
Bleistift Bleistifte
der Bundstift buntstifte
der Kugelreiber
kugelreiber ya da kısaca der ki die
kulis
der füller die föller
der radium die radier gummis
Der spitzer die spitzer
der Ordner dir.
Der tibtisch
die Schreibtische.
Stüle
der Rechner
der Taschenrechner
der laptop der computer.
D artikel kelimelere geçmeden önce şunu
hatırlatayım. Eğer kelimenin sonundaki
harf E harfi ise bu size bir ipucu
olsun. O zaman artikeli her zaman için D
olur. Başlayalım.
D kaydı.
Kiden
die sheren,
die mappe di mappen,
di taş di taşın.
Bir kelimenin sonunda yine taşı varsa
bir çeşit çantadır. Göreceğiz şimdi. Ve
artiklinde her zaman için d olur.
Dişul taşı.
Sporttasche
tafel
die pinwand
kartı.
Das artikeline bakalım.
Das heft die hefte.
Das Buch, die Bücher,
das Wörterbuch
das Mppchen,
das papier
papir
das handy, the handys. Bunlar
kelimelerimizdi.
Şimdi cümle kurabiliriz artık ama bunun
için bize bir fiil lazım. Bu fiilimiz de
z yani olmak fiili. Hemen fiil çekimini
koyalım. Ama burada sadece bize iki tane
çekim hali lazım. Tekil eşyaları tarif
ederken o yani derken isti
kullanmalıyım. Çoğul halini çekerken
zint kullanmalıyım. Yani tekil eşyalarda
is çoğullarda zint fiili çekilmiş halini
kullanmam lazım. Öyleyse başlayalım. Bu
o kalem. Önce belirli artikelden
başlayalım. Bu ne demek? Bu o kalem.
Yani ben size belirli bildiğim bir
kalemden bahsediyorum. Ya da bunlar o
kalemler. O kalemleri tarif ediyorum.
Bildiğim kalemler.
O durumda cümleyi nasıl kurarız? Yani
belirli bir nesneyi tanımlarken önce
cümlenin başına does, tekil eşya için
does kalıbını yazarım. Sonra artikeli
yazarım. Yani kelimenin hangi artikeli
varsa onu yazarım. En sona da nesneyi
yazarım.
Eğer çoğul eşyaları tarif edersem dozin
şeklinde kullanırım kalıbımı. D
artikelini kullanmak zorundayım. Bütün
çoğul eşyaların artikeli diddir. Ve
sonana nesne değil nesneler yani çoğul
halini yazarım. Örnek verelim mesela
tekil eşyalarla. Bunlar benim bildiğim
eşyalar.
Do ist bu bir kalıp. Bunu ezberliyoruz.
Bu bir
istift bu o kalem.
Bu o makas
bu o kitap yani o benim aradığım kitap
şeklinde belirli bir şeyi kastediyorum
demektir. Çoğul olursa doesn't
bunlar o kitaplar. Bunlar benim aradığım
kitaplar tarzında. Bu cümleyi bununla
kullanabiliriz.
Ya da bizi bir şey bahsederken yani bu
bir kalemdir, bu bir eşyadır gibi genel
bir ifade kullanırsak
örneğin bu bir kalemdir derken herhangi
bir kalemden bahsediyorumdur.
Bunlar kalemlerdir derken o zaman da
yine herhangi kalemlerden
bahsediyorumdur.
Yani kısacası herhangi bir nesneyi
tanımlarken yine doesi başa koyacağım.
Bu sefer 1 kelimesini kullanmam lazım.
Bu da aynı ya da aynı şeklinde olmalı.
En sona yine nesneyi koydum. Çoğul cümle
kurarken ayn yani biri kullanmam mümkün
değil. Çünkü çoğuldan bahsediyorum. Does
zint fiili zin'e göre kullandım. Doint
artı nesneler. Örnekle daha iyi anlarız.
Ayn ya da aynı. Bunu neye göre karar
verebilirim? Eğer tarif ettiğim eşyanın
artikeli there ya da does ise
kullanmalıyım. Tarif ettiğim eşyanın
artikeli D ise aynı kullanmalıyım.
Örneğin tekil eşya ve çoğul eşyalarımı
yazdım.
Is their stift. Bu o kalem. Şimdi bunu
belirsiz hale getirelim. Bu bir kalem
diyelim.
Stift.
Mapı. Bu o dosya. Bunu değiştirelim.
Mapı. Burada E harfini arttırdım. Çünkü
kelimemin artikeli theist aynı mapı.
Das is bu o kitap değiştirelim.
Buh. Bu bir kitap. Çoğulda da ne
yaparız? Do püse. Bunlar kitaplardır
deriz. Herhangi bir şey zinden sonra
kullanmadım.
Deiftas.
Bu bir kalıptır. Bunu tekilde de çoğulda
da kullanabilirsiniz.
Yani bu böyle ezberlenecek bir cümle
kalıbı.
Bu nedir?
Bu bir kalem.
K harfini koydum ve olumsuz hale
getirdim.
Kin stift. Bu bir kalem değil.
M stift. Bu benim kalemim dedim.
D artikelinde her zaman e harfini
arttırmayı unutmayın.
dasere
keine
artikeli artikeli ile benzer olacak.
Aynı şekilde ist
das heft
heft
ve çoğul dpen unutmayın çoğulun artikeli
d idi. O yüzden burada da e harfi artmak
zorunda. Bist does bakın tekil olarak
sordum çünkü bu bir kalıp demiştim.
Fiilin çoğul halini kullanıyorum. Onlar
olduğu için doesn't mappen.
Sen keine mappen.
Mappen.
Şimdi istift. Bu bir kalemdir. Bunu
öğrendik. Şimdi farklı bir cümle
kuralım. V ile başlamayan bir cümle
kurmak için fiili en başa alalım ve bir
soru cümlesi meydana getirelim. Bu nasıl
bir soru cümlesi? Bu bir kalem mi yani
sonunda mi gibi ek olan sorular. Yani
cevabı evet ya da hayır olan sorular.
Şimdi iki seçeneğim var. Evet ya da
hayır. Kaleme bakıyorum. Ya evet. Ya das
ist ein. Evet bu bir kalem.
Hayır bu bir kalem değil. Ne ist bu
kalem değil. Ne is bu şekilde
söyleyebilirsiniz. Hayır bu bir kitap
diyebilirsiniz.
Örneklerimizde çoğulla devam edelim.
Aynı şekilde fiilimi başa aldım. Geri
kalanları da arkasına yazdım ve soru
işaretimi koydum. Bunlar kalem mi? Zinft
ya. Evet.
Bunlar kalemler.
Nein, keine stifte.
Nein, das sind büyüke.
Basit s cümle de kurabiliriz artık.
Bunun için yine aynı fiili kullanacağım.
Yani zine fiili.
Unutmayalım. Tekil eşyalarda is
kullanıyorduk. Çoğul eşyalarda ise ne
kullanıyorduk? O zaman da zint yani
olmak fiilinin is ve zind
basit sıfatlı cümleleri kurarken tabii
ki neye ihtiyacımız var? Sıfatlara
ihtiyacımız var. Hemen bakalım. Kleine,
gross,
alt, noy. Bunlar bizim kelimelerimiz
ve kuracağım cümle çok kolay. Özneyi
başa yazdım. Fiili her zamanki gibi
ikiye yazdım ve sıfatımı en sona koydum.
Stift is kfte.
Çoğul bir cümle. Stifte sind gr.
[Müzik]
Dersimiz sona erdi.
Kalem kılıçtan güçlüdür der. Edward
Bulvar Lon. PDF dosyası ekledim. İndirip
çalışabilirsiniz. Yine oyun linkleri
üzerinden alıştırma yapabilirsiniz. Bir
sonraki derste görüşmek üzere. Hoşça
kalın. Bak